so this might be one of the most
powerful episodes of the think media
podcast that you ever listen to and
we're going to be talking about really
Next Level strategies to take your
online business your income your wealth
building to another level and I'm
talking with Neil dingra who's a
financial expert a content creator
millions of views building a team
building a business all knows all kinds
of tax advantages and even if you're a
beginner this is the kind of
conversation I wish I could sit on the
wall and listen to back when I was
starting
and to help me go further faster and
maybe even make different chess moves in
my journey of starting and growing in
the crater economy but also protecting
my wealth and scaling my business
overall so Neil welcome back to the
podcast thanks for having me man
appreciate it so I'm fired up to get
into this we were brainstorming uh off
camera we jumped on the phone and we
came up with like five questions
creators should be asking that are kind
of like next level thinking
um and this is sort of inspired by the
idea that creators are doing big things
right now I see you know Mr Beast of
course Mr Beast got a lot of money but
he's doing like Mr Beast Burger he's
um doing all kinds of different merch
projects our friend Ryan Pineda launched
a big nft project generated millions of
dollars and of course is also
diversifying in a real estate other
businesses he's starting you look at
someone like Shelby Church who opened up
an Airbnb business a lot of creators are
doing that there's tax advantages with
these things there's different creators
that are using the money they're
generating and they're investing it in
future things and then there's also a
lot of things happening where even if
you're just at a lower level even maybe
making 50k a year there's some big
savings you could have if you're more
strategic with your income and so the
first question we wrote down and I'd
love for you to brainstorm on this is is
how can I strategically
reinvest into my business some creators
start making some money and then they
just start buying dumb stuff yeah so how
do you think when you think about
generating income and then actually
reinvesting it into your business I
think the first thing you could do and
this is the first hire for everybody is
someone that could help you increase
your output so we talked about on
another podcast how to even just hire an
editor you know a lot of I know so many
creators I know high level creators that
edit every single one of their own
videos and it's like that's that could
be outsourced for a certain amount that
would allow you to produce even more
content and distribute that content
across all these platforms and we have
such a unique opportunity right now
where you can reach so many people you
know as these as these platforms are
growing and new products are growing so
I think that's like the first thing of
like hey you're making this extra money
maybe defer or like you know delay
gratification of you got this extra
money now instead of spending it on
something like the car or the trip or
whatever it is that you want
put it into the business with that new
hire or with that equipment that would
upgrade the look of your content I mean
a lot of people are shooting with not
the best equipment and their excuse is
is that the platform doesn't really care
you can shoot and that's true for
getting started but at a certain level
the quality does matter and I've noticed
you get better better Quality
Connections based on the quality of your
content you know just simple things like
mics and lights and all that kind of
stuff so I would invest in the quality
of the content first and also someone to
help you distribute produce more content
increase the output yeah it's beautiful
and I think on number one how can I
strategically reinvest my business
another way to put that was how could I
buy more time yes by by investing in a
team member now you're able to go
produce more
um yeah a couple that I think about on
that one would absolutely especially
towards the end of the year in tax time
do we want to hire more people do we
want to purchase any equipment and
here's a question for you you know
depending on what tax bracket you're in
sometimes people say hey go buy a car
buy a car that's six thousand pounds and
write it all off in the same year
and that might make sense but if you go
buy a hundred thousand dollar car and
save twenty five thousand dollars on it
because of taxes that still cost you
seventy five thousand dollars and you
instead could actually get into
employees or a part-time person a couple
contractors you know somebody that's
just say 45k helping you distribute your
content what has been your mindset in
that do you see that uh would you when
you were starting out would you buy the
car or would you invest in your business
well it's easy to say now it's the right
decision but I mean I did all the dumb
stuff growing up you know buying the
cars and and spending the money but I
think now hindsight 2020 definitely the
better decision would be to reinvest in
the actual thing that made you the money
sure so instead of extracting it let's
just do more of the thing you know and I
think people use their business as a you
know just a piggy bank to Rob yeah you
know and it should be like something
that actually grows and you invest in we
had an interesting conversation with
garyvee at an event recently and he we
asked him like Hey Gary how do you do
all these things that are so successful
when you're not really you know um
you're not really talking about how you
were able to do all of these unscalable
things and all these different companies
and all of them are really successful
like he had the same success with all
these companies and nfts and all that
stuff that we talked about and he said
it's because I didn't need the money
right and it's it's kind of easy for him
to say you might say because he's you
know already wealthy but even in the
beginning he talked about how he lived
with his family on meager you know money
and just took whatever money he had and
invested it in early stage companies
that's what got him to the first level
of wealth so like delaying the
gratification seems to be the formula in
the beginning for people how they got to
like next level wealth was they they
took that 50 Grand which isn't much or
that 10 grand which isn't much and
instead of spending it they invested it
in an early stage company or in
themselves or in their own company I
love that delayed gratification was a
bomb drop for sure because so many
people want it right now not realizing
that even if you maybe didn't buy that
car for one two three years then you
might be able to buy 10 cars because of
the scale that be could be created
because of reinvesting in your business
um you know what's funny is uh
personally we were even just thinking
about we just had a second baby and um
and we have a 2016 Ford Explorer come on
sport turbocharged but this thing's six
years old now right I could buy whatever
car I want at this exact moment but even
talking to my wife we went around we
were like we were gonna get like a
Toyota Sequoia 2022 TRD and then we are
looking at prices and we're like this
thing's 80k and this is just us we lean
way more to that garyvee style I was
like man this car is fine we could drive
this thing until the wheel Falls Wheels
fall off but on the flip side we also
are looking at making about a half a
million dollar investment over 12 month
period in hiring and raising is at this
moment as well so that's real money and
so trying to play the long game it's
also kind of maybe long game versus
short game thinking as well like our our
Ford Explorer is cool our Jeep is cool
and so
um and I don't think there's anything
wrong with like wanting nicer things to
get like I can't say anything I I bought
a Lambo you know a year ago so they
might be thinking oh you're a hypocrite
well no I waited 20 years to share that
card literally two decades of doing the
thing and trying to figure out success
and buying all the real estate first so
I think when you start to invest it's
going to allow you to get instead of
getting the Toyota now you can maybe get
the Lexus or you know you're going to
have even better things coming in the
future if you could delay that initial
gratification so powerful okay so the
second question is what new product or
service could I create that would solve
my audiences or clients problems so a
Next Level question you came up with
this one expand on if someone listening
to this why they should ask this and
maybe how you would apply this question
so let's say you're having success in
your uh in your journey maybe it's with
content creation for example that's an
easy one you know say you're helping
you're doing content creation you're
able to apply it to your business to get
more clients and grow that business
you're now you've gone from Step A to B
you are now qualified to teach the
people how to go from A to B there's
this interesting phenomenon where people
no longer want to learn from a guy who's
10 20 steps ahead they'd like to learn
from a guy who's two steps ahead or a
gal that's one step ahead reason being
is now I feel I can do this so you can
monetize that by creating courses
coaching mentorship and I think a lot of
people feel like they're not qualified
because this space is kind of littered
with scams and all that but if you are a
genuine person you have knowledge to
share and you really want to help people
go from A to B and you've done that
there's nothing more powerful than
saying I'm going to teach you what I
just did that is a monetizable thing so
I think there's a lot of products
informational products that we're
sitting on that are sitting you know in
in our mind that you could throw into a
course on any one of these learning
platforms and it's it's just putting
taking the time aside to shoot that
content and then I've noticed this does
the best in today's market is a course
plus some sort of updating mechanism
such as I'll do a call with you a group
call every month or every bi-weekly or
it could be of course that updates I add
modules to this every 60 days or
whatever that is so it's not just a
static thing and there's a lot of money
to be made in the information space if
it's you know if it's actually helping
people so there's maybe a lot of things
that could apply to this but to be even
more clear you're suggesting that people
really join the e-learning info space
yeah it is a multi-multi-billion dollar
space and we need more people who are
actually subject matter experts so let's
just say your subject matter expert at
real estate at anything at equipment
whatever you know
uh you should teach you know and and I
think people feel like they're not
qualified to but if you are a true
expert at that you should put that into
a product and monetize that and uh not
feel bad about that at all yeah it's
powerful and and I believe the same
thing I think you know the stat from
Forbes was that by 2025 it was going to
be a trillion dollar a day industry or
something like that and not only that
just the idea that it's also one of the
best business models or products to sell
because of fulfillment because of cost
because of margins
um if it's a digital course or if it's
e-learning or a membership of some time
uh some kind it's it's not Drop Shipping
it's not shipping containers it's not
fulfilled by Amazon's cut on the price
think about like a super basic level
like if you don't even want to do that
create a document you know an ebook yeah
and if you're not good at design just
write it down on a Google doc give it to
a graphics Diner make it look like a
nice book sell that thing for five to
ten bucks passively and create it once
it just continues it's a leverage yeah
because you create it once but you can
sell it multiple times so are creating
leverage and so this is these are some
good questions that you could be asked
at any time but this also might be
annual it's good to go through this you
know I would definitely ask these
questions if it was like December and
this particular question might apply to
slowing down in your business and
thinking about
um where am I where am I now like what
did I just do what did I do over the
last six to 12 months that I can maybe
now teach on you and I both have an
event yeah and so we've been doing our
event for five years you've been doing
yours for a few years probably wouldn't
want to teach on events before we've
done it or after one time but actually
my goodness we could save people tens of
thousands of dollars if not hundreds of
thousands and you can show them
opportunities to make money from the
events right because all the lessons you
learned all the lessons we learned so we
could look back what have we done now
and so if you're listening that course
doesn't even exist yeah it is can't come
to think of it we're brainstorming right
now like and it's of course I would love
to pay for because you know we spent
nearly a million dollars actually on
growth video live 2022 and uh it was
profitable we it turned out incredibly
well but all that to say my God the
level of lessons I've learned you as
well so where are you you're listening
to this where are you right now to look
back and say what have I just learned
and I love what you said you've gone to
A to B you left a you arrived at B you
got that result it doesn't mean you've
been at F for D you know I I definitely
don't want to create the course how to
become a billionaire certainly haven't
done it so uh where are you now okay
let's go to the third question
how can I strengthen my brand and my
market positioning why is this a
powerful
thought exercise well I think people
aren't thinking big enough you know and
uh we were just talking about this today
at an event in a client service business
yeah you get fired and nobody tells you
right so for example like if I'm
searching for people and maybe I work
with this guy and I don't find any
content on him online and somebody else
you know Woos me with their content and
I end up reaching out to them because I
feel more comfortable reaching out to
that person because they have a stronger
brand than you yeah I don't call the
person I left and say hey you know what
you really didn't have a good digital
footprint so I'm gonna go with somebody
else you just don't get the call you
don't know but your business just starts
to slowly erode and that's what happens
is you know people are taking there's
abundance there's a business there's
enough business out there for everybody
but at a certain point
you know when I get a client in my
industry that could have gone somewhere
else so you know that's the K it's just
that's just the way the business works
so you have to think about like what can
you do to strengthen your brand so you
get more of those conversions more
people reaching out to you
um or when somebody's considering
working with you how could you
strengthen that conversion process so
that's somebody reaching out and then to
the time when you actually get paid how
can we make that ratio higher and that's
through having a strong personal brand
and content so you know this is probably
an underrated part because people are
looking to monetize right away but
that's probably been the biggest way
I've monetize my personal brand is
people just want to work with you and
they don't consider the competition once
they've seen your content I'm surprised
at somebody watching five minutes of
videos crushes my competition in five
minutes I haven't even spoken to them
yet yeah now I get on the phone with
them conversion rates Sky High because
they already trust you based on the
content they saw online and it's amazing
how many people in a client service
business do not exist properly online so
that's a great place to start as
somebody listening to this is just like
make sure your digital presence is is
dialed in yeah on all these platforms
and invest the time to do that that's
really good and this one actually kind
of gets me fired up because I have been
very personally intentional about this
uh probably more than most
um and we didn't get where we're at in
think media by accident or I didn't get
even where I am with my personal brand
by accident so when I think about this
things that I wanted to do one write a
book and of course you never know how
good the book's going to do but the a
brand Authority and positioning of over
80 000 copies sold of YouTube secrets of
it ranking on Amazon I've also like my
friend uh Chandler bolt he has
self-publishing school a book is like a
business card and so that's a powerful
one you and I both throw an event and
throwing event with we pay big money for
keynote speakers that maybe are an
anchor like a garyvee growth video live
2022 for us was actually a brand play if
I said it more than anything else it was
a brand positioning and so thank God it
was profitable and it was impactful and
of course it's about the you you don't
even want to be in business if you're
not about serving the end user and
making it a great experience it's not
just an event for pictures and it sucks
like obviously you gotta follow through
but nevertheless it it repositioned
think media you mentioned content so
even if you were at the end of the year
or at any time how can I do more content
this next year or staff or team around
it or contractors another thing we're
doing we're doing a study it's very
expensive
but it's kind of like Dave Ramsey where
he goes we've done the largest study of
everyday millionaires like in history so
he becomes a market research leader with
a real
um weighted National study and so
contributing our voice will give the
study away for free but now in the
crater economy so these are all
different Investments and we're going
these are Next Level questions and those
would increase your brand positioning
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
I know in some cases some people invest
in services to help them get in Forbes
or success or these different articles
because maybe those those logos but by
growing your brand you mentioned the ROI
of that of course is your perception it
might help uh conversions
it might help conversations or sales
conversations go faster it might almost
help them become unnecessary because
you've already built trust and people
want to do business with you and so how
can I strengthen my brand and Market
positioning think about that as you are
on your journey all right it's one of my
favorites number four how can I reduce
my taxes now we've already kind of
mentioned some of these because early on
if I invest into my business that's a
write-off if I invest in something
that's not a write-off then I'm not
reducing my taxes maybe the car used for
business great I actually am going to be
able to get a tax advantage there but in
some cases there's a lot of things I
could spend money on it may not be a
write-off and I'm going to get so much
more leverage if I my money's going to
go farther my business money is pre-tax
the money I've made is a 1099 Creator
when YouTube pays me ad Revenue when
Amazon pays me affiliate money when I
click money for my online course I have
not paid taxes yet and I do not pay
taxes until I have to pay quarterly at
least estimated and then eventually when
my taxes are due therefore I am not
getting a tax return huge myth people
are like I'm getting a tax return no the
government actually just took your money
and now they're giving it back to you
they held it all year long you could
have held it all year long had more
leverage with it done things with it and
so how do you think about taxes I think
it's like it's some of it's unavoidable
but you have to think like what are the
things that I could do to be more tax
efficient and you know I I hate when
people are like you know I don't want to
make this much or get into this because
I'm going to pay more taxes well one of
the common misconceptions is like the
tax brackets are not retroactive the
next tax bracket is on the income above
the previous one you know so it's just
that section so I would strive to be in
the top tax bracket you know like that
means you're crushing it right but
there's things you can do to bring down
the tax liability make strategic
investments before the end of the year
one simple thing that I noticed a lot of
people don't even have set up is a
separate entity so you are a sole
proprietor as a Creator or whatever
business you're running and you're
filing that on Schedule C you should set
up a separate company you know because
there's tax benefits associated with
that you could talk to your CPA but LLC
or an S corp or something to that effect
and then now you can make those
deductions there you can reduce payroll
taxes there's all kinds of little things
you can do and then you know you start
to get into like these little things
that have a small impact but combined in
the aggregate like they make it make a
decent size difference you know so all
the little tax efficiencies you can do
one thing I noticed with investing is
you know with we talked about real
estate you know real estate for your
business is one thing but just in
general investing your extra money into
real estate uh income coming from Real
Estate is probably is the most favorably
treated by the IRS you know that's why
all these guys are getting into real
estate a lot of times with the income
because passive income from Real Estate
you get depreciation write-offs uh you
know there's all kinds of benefits to
that and now you're paying like
sometimes zero tax on the income that
you're getting from Real Estate and
that's a huge benefit there's things
like people will buy a property and do a
uh cost segregation analysis which
sounds complex but basically you get a
huge write-off in the first year of
owning that property which can offset
your taxes across the board so you know
I've seen people super wealthy buying
ridiculous you know a building or in
Grant cardone's case a plane and then
that wiping out is tax liability for
years I mean that's crazy but that's an
extreme example but you can do this on a
one-off basis with just one rental
property
so what's on your mind uh as you
approach maybe the end of the year or
any time
um personally you're at a at a high
level
um but just your checklist what what
would you go through in terms of like I
want to invest in my business and I I
understand this will also be a tax
benefit and I want to like get this done
by the end of the year so one thing I
did which I didn't really spend much
time with before was getting a CPA or a
Tax Advisor because you know I don't
know all these things I don't know the
strategy and I don't want to do anything
that would put me at risk so getting
that person and then having a tax
planning session before the end of the
year so what I'll do is like in November
hey let's review how much money have you
made like where are you at where's the
numbers at is there anything we can do
between now and the end of the year to
uh decrease your tax liability is there
anything we could do between now and the
end of the year to um make your return
better next year you know things like
that that you could just put in these
guys are experts you can pay them you
know for that session and I it's always
a huge Roi especially when you get into
the higher numbers yeah that's really
powerful and we actually have a series
that we did with
um Matt Bontrager from True books on the
think media podcast we'll link that up
in the show notes
um really yeah his content's amazing his
content's really great and and I would
also I want to encourage you it's this
is kind of overwhelming
um and it can it could be a lot to learn
but one of the best investments
education wise you can make is in your
financial education
um and a lot of people just lose a ton
of money because they're not thoughtful
about this they don't get Incorporated
they don't get organized they don't they
don't learn the tax code and so they
don't actually end up using it to their
advantage personally this is when you
and I talk about a lot I'm inspired by
space station gaming space station
gaming is in Utah they've bought they
bought like ten thousand fifteen
thousand square feet giant Warehouse
they put shipping containers in it
they've got an Esports team there's some
studios in there they have a brand deals
business where they help people get
brand deals and they have comp pounded
their success so you and I are talking
about you know in Vegas here we want to
uh we've been looking at like a a larger
house that maybe has no HOA what we
could do on the property just because
we'd use it for like shooting or events
or masterminds we're looking at
Commercial Real Estate that we would
maybe build out a friend of mine David
Shands I'm about to speak for him he's
got I think it's called like the Creator
Clubhouse in Atlanta and he got 3 000
square feet he built two podcast Studios
he built an 80 person virtual events
Studio that he himself can use but he
can also rent it out so you could get
some money and just let it get taxed and
put it in the bank account not bad
because sometimes taxes are avoidable
you just pay the bill uh you also could
buy a car or you could think about like
I'm buying a building not only is that a
write-off but I also just started a
whole new business now I can rent out
these podcast Studios I maybe want to
use these for myself and that's what we
hope is inspiring just a Next Level way
of thinking yeah just thinking bigger
thinking bigger
and back to that again I think okay I'm
putting off the Toyota which is so chill
uh but I'm like instead of and I've
heard some people say yeah instead of
the uh the car get get put it into real
estate I know some people's principle is
until I get real estate cash flowing me
the money to pay for my liabilities I'm
going to invest in assets
um and so how can I reduce my taxes well
the final one and let me recap these so
number one you're asking how can I
strategically reinvest in my business
number two what product or service could
I create that would solve my audiences
or clients problems specifically
packaging what you know into an online
course even if that's not your main
business even if that's not what you
thought you were going to do the
e-learning industry is massive it's
coming up to be a trillion dollar a day
industry and so tapping into that once
you've gotten it from A to B uh package
your knowledge and start to sell it
number three how can I strengthen my
brand and my market positioning um you
know
one of the things we also sometimes
think about is like prepaying marketing
uh and pre-paying for maybe something
that's a service for our brand and so if
we do that before the end of the year we
know we want to work with someone who is
going to do some PR or branding for
example we paid for this study that we
do we are doing that was nearly a
hundred thousand dollars we paid for it
last December it's not even done yet we
just wanted to get it off our books they
said you can make payments we said we
don't want to we want to pay the whole
because we knew we wanted to do the
whole thing in which you hear when it
comes to taxes is this idea of kicking
the can right and just continuously
kicking the can down the road forever if
possible and so um how can I strengthen
my brand and my market positioning how
can I reduce my taxes and then finally
how can I protect my business during a
recession you've created some great
content on this
um uncertain economies are a whole
different landscape and so maybe you
have some money but you don't want to go
stretch yourself into a loan a
construction loan a commercial maybe you
want to be conservative I don't know
what's your take in the midst of being
in a recession uncertain economy or
looming economic uncertainty I think you
want to invest in a lot of the things we
talked about like brand positioning
things like that are going to be more
elevated during the recession so in a
recession you know the money the flow of
money from people to companies and vice
versa just slows down so that money's
still there in this case it's a unique
recession because money's being eroded
by inflation right so you need to make
more money than ever before and you need
to invest in things that can produce
money so I think like what are the
Investments you could make that could
increase your cash flow that could
protect your business when you talk
about Brand's the ultimate protection
for your business because that's a moat
you know around your company that took
you years to build to build and same
thing with the content stuff like we
were talking about putting out more
content that really helps to protect you
get you you more business and the one
thing you can do in a recession is make
more money and then invest that into
things that will protect you my favorite
is residential real estate
um you know rental properties because of
the tax advantages of that and then also
because of the fact that it's always
going to be needed like I don't have to
follow the price day to day sometimes
you know you watch the stock market it
gives you a little bit of illness
because it's just up and down and you
worried about your money all the time
with hard assets it's like I know this
property is there it could be
residential commercial and it's always
going to produce income and the value
can fluctuate in the short run but in
the long run it's always going to be
there producing income and that income
is treated more favorably sometimes has
zero tax liability so that's amazing and
that's unique to real estate so that's
why I put a lot of money there but I
just think of whatever you're thinking
of doing in a recession you need to
focus on a making making sure that your
cash flow doesn't go down because that's
what happens to most people and then
that's how you get into debt and all
these things go out the window because
now you're not making enough money to
keep things going so focus on that cash
flow first
yeah you know one of the things I love
you said too is actually crank up your
content and I think for us Double Down
double down on your content in
recessionary periods and it wasn't
really a recession but it was one of the
crazy Seasons you and I both lived
through I remember back March 2020 the
economy well people get stay at home
orders
um that month
um the month previous we had just hired
people and we just paid a tax bill and
so we were negative thirty thousand
dollars on our p l in February then in
March the economy and the lockdown order
stay in place happen and we're like what
is going to happen we're like already
the p l is not looking good in hindsight
it was just a month where everything was
really concentrated but nevertheless we
had actually just kind of scaled up uh
we hired a couple people into the team I
think it was like Nolan and Tony and we
makes it some big moves at the time and
then March happened and I remember I had
a choice as a leader do I go into the
recession mindset and constrict and go
on defense or do I go on offense
and it kind of built a cultural
principle for us at think media yet
defense is important protection
insurance
um caution
but you're never gonna win if you never
score
it would be impossible at least it'd be
a tie if all you ever did is play play
defense you just it was a zero zero
because just nobody scored but
ultimately the only way you're ever
going to win is you got to actually put
points on the board and so we like to
ask when we think about recession man
how could we just keep playing offense
and what's interesting is sometimes the
psychology of the masses are to really
constrict so actually by being on
offense I think my favorite analogy is
when I think about March 2020 and then
the preceding months the world kind of
froze and everyone just didn't know what
to do and it reminds me of this scene in
Forrest Gump I don't know if you
remember if you've seen the movie
they're on this boat Lieutenant Dan is
uh and there's a storm that comes and
Lieutenant Dan's on the top of the he's
like God if you get us through this
storm and Forest is down below like
tying the ropes and he's you know and
this it's this crazy scene boom it fast
forward flash forward to the next day
and they've been catching zero shrimp in
their shrimp business next day all the
boats are sidelined and they're up on
they're in the water they're on the
shore and they're just trolling there
through the bay and there is nobody else
but them and now these shrimp are in
abundance and so that makes me think is
that if you can kind of ride out the
storm and still be out there fishing and
you can ride out the storm and stay on
offense and not get sidelined not get
Frozen a lot of people either run they
freeze they constrict you stay on
offense during a recession
um you actually may the money like not
all the money disappeared it just
changed hands right and and even if
certain people are experiencing economic
hardship there's empathy for that but
there's still money being spent you just
want to make sure you're the one that's
at least still out there fishing you
just want to be on the right side of the
register yeah yeah and uh and I love
that you specifically mentioned content
double down on content and and one of
our responses to that time and at this
very moment we very well could be in a
progressively worse recession and who
knows
um you know we also made a decision to
double down on content we started two
shows the coffee with candle show we
started
um Heather showed that YouTube Made
Simple show which were weekly live shows
and we we actually said we want to be
more there for our community especially
with encouragement with content we want
to stay top of mind and and it was like
we're not we're not shaking back we are
pressing ahead and doubling down yeah
and it's a huge time to take market
share yeah from competitors who you say
like are pulling back companies pull
back because of budget things and their
stocks are down and they do it like I we
we had this thing where we're seeing big
companies laying off people reducing
spending because that's what they have
to do to appease the shareholders they
have to cut expenses and they're kind of
like stuck you know in those kinds of
things you as an individual or a small
company or you know a team of three or a
team of one you can be very
you know and you'd be like hey I want to
double down okay I'm going to do that
and a lot of things are just going to
take more time so that's not even like
you know money invested that's just your
time and so I think that's it's like I
don't know what it is but people just
get super uh reluctant to invest because
of the fear
and if you're doing it in the right way
in a thoughtful way it's probably the
best investment you can make it's during
that slowdown like and that's probably
what we're going to see and then if
we're being you know looking at all the
data we don't know exactly how it's
going to play out but over the next six
to 12 months Market's going to be slow
the economy's slowing down for sure yeah
well I hope this episode's been
encouraging and uh highly recommended to
follow Neil
um because you're going to get more
tactical stuff not just from this
episode but as we proceed through the
ups and the Downs of the economy he's
packed full of all kinds of wisdom and
so if people want to connect with you
where they where can they follow you
online
um you can find me on YouTube but the
best place to message me or connect with
me is on Instagram Neil home
foreign